three two one five seven eight - welcome
to punch drunk [ __ ] faces ladies and
gentlemen spinning on its axis circling
a star in the middle of the universe its
punch of sports and ladies and gentlemen
Ari Shaffir is here I'm here with sports
band hey fight nany Johnny Woodard and
ladies and gentlemen
Ari Shaffir who seems naked and he's
laying on the carpet somewhere is that
what you call it that's a stretch that
is that was a stretch and that's a
stretch
yeah he's done oh he really is
stretching it out ladies and gentlemen
look at this
Aries Schieffer really going for it ari
I've been watching your skiing videos
and I am really am
max you must be having so much fun
because you've been skiing like a lot in
the last like week or two twelve
thirteen days in this year some of the
best places in the world
you've now skied more times than I have
in my life in 13 days what I've skied
less than 13 times in my life I was
always pretty bad and then like really
good don't forget the ski with Ryan
who's better than me you're really good
at slowing down and then picking up
speed I've been watching your style my
technique is terrible but like but like
John pigeon Joe's always done that right
leg is always coming in oh yeah yeah
yeah I used to ski all the time how's
your snowplow my snow plows [ __ ]
OnPoint
the rezident breaking news punch-drunk
fans
Ari Shaffir has all of his toes red band
fell for that you thought he lost a toe
I did you really lose a toe and I'm like
yep I was concerned
yep I was telling here I mean it wasn't
going to be but now sure yeah absolutely
that's exactly how that went I was like
oh will you believe this - I'm surprised
you
but now I'm gonna let you go that
direction so are you into yoga now
because of the the challenge he was into
it before that no he was into it when he
went overseas when he pulled the Dave
Chappelle and lost his mind
and he's like Chappelle went to Africa
and Ari went to wherever little boys are
that you can [ __ ] then he got into yoga
actually it's a lot of places you have
like a dead body if you're gay you have
a dead body so far yeah but I'm saying
like look at look at okay are you
definition he's like skinny fit oh look
at whoa that's elastic like Oh elastin
is impressive that you can stretch ari
if she wasn't already pregnant sounds
like she wants it
Sam's got like a grand dad bod Sam has
Abbas is your kids your kids I used to
know you or you slept for two now it is
gonna be a girl have you talked about
names yet yes what about Porsche some
something's gonna get on the pole
quickly no what about dumb [ __ ] that's
something you wouldn't what about a book
what about a black name like shampoo or
[ __ ] uh Shaniqua no no you guys go
you guys asked before or no cool names
what is it I don't tell you but do you
have it down cuz you are yeah yeah it
seems like you are 40 days away from
that would be good and then that would
be good beautiful that's a real name
what about [ __ ] see one of the top three
[ __ ] - King
if it comes out black is this baby gonna
be black
that's impossible I mean what about like
some old well you better call it John
Pinette John the Navy wouldn't it be
more plausible that it would have been a
Mexican if anything no I mean if it's a
Mexican that's one more reason to build
the wall that's all the current father
would like he doesn't like to be
reminded about Nick Diaz 209 what about
if that's even what what have you just
what if you name it what if you just
named your daughter at the time you guys
met you and the father Matt and you call
it a 209 30
[Laughter]
how about Zipit [ __ ] Oh like Ari I would
have a daughter like Ari and I would
have a daughter all right sorry got that
dude can we give me pinky swear on that
pinky swear people swear pinkies yep
totally into it so Ari how long do we
have you
Wow you know like where are you at you
looks like you're in a very luxurious
place what do you have on phones
Oh air B&B I thought you would look like
you were in a very luxurious hotel Vegas
huh yeah it sure does looks like a suite
no looks like a shooter hotel but
instead you are rooting through other
people's things and stretching naked on
their floor you got your [ __ ] all
over their floor while you're stretching
brand and bod
come in on the floor and the carpets and
stuff oh and the red band does everyone
okay I do I come with underwear like no
one can see like you can all have to
step in it just like you know just like
jizz on your way out so it's like it
visit my corner at the end I'm just like
I don't walk barefoot in hotel rooms cuz
of animals oh of course not you know a
lot of Airbnb s have hidden cameras in
them because they want to protect their
property so like if Ari goes crazy and
destroys it that they at least have
video of it so they they have these
things you can buy where you can scan
your room to see if there's cameras and
I forget which website did it and they
like one out of like ten Airbnb they
test it had a hidden cameras in it would
that even stop you from doing the things
you do if it's over something like oh he
put his balls in in the my cup or
something like that right he was like oh
you're gonna break the code for that no
it's only if you destroy the place and
it's like like they could watch you
upset the ones they found were in
usually fire fire detectors or whatever
they call it fire alarms it's not legal
to record audio but I think you're fine
if it's video and you own the property
yeah there's no laws on you yeah I'm not
sure though the state's probably
different yeah alright what are you
drinking coffee water come type what is
it - ah hot ginger so happy now it's
called it's called I'm making money I'm
making money and I can upgrade what I
spend money on like coffee coffee is
either like three or fifty cents but
like giant hot diet ginger is like 11
bucks and he's like [ __ ] it it's like
[ __ ] face [ __ ] face [ __ ] face you know
what you've become
remember when you were in the airport
with Rogan and you go oh [ __ ]
and Rogan goes what's wrong and there's
like season two of a fear factor mmm
right so Brogan's like make a mad money
and Ari's I [ __ ] and Rogen's like what
they're like going through Denver like
you know taxi in their [ __ ] luggage
and uh
Ari's like I forgot toothpaste oh yeah
remember and Rogin and a run goes dude
who cares just buy toothpaste how much
the toothpaste like ten bucks and I was
like aha
you're red I think he said twenty books
I think it's more than all right what is
it 10 or 20 yeah for a year toothpaste
is ten bucks for a year
that's who you become I remember when
you were like alright what are you
drinking right now and you're like
pretty much my own spit and now you're
like what are you doing or now imported
ginger uh you know like okay okay
[ __ ] we get it I get a $10
toothpaste I get it the problem with
Jason is he doesn't eat fruit or
vegetables so he doesn't understand what
you're saying
what makes you when we take this outside
because you know what you'll give birth
in five minutes
in the parking lot what's your one
sidekick what's your reasoning for
drinking ginger they're like candy Ari
yeah I try to cut down but in Asia I
really there wasn't really much sugar
stuff so I I kind of ridding myself of
the habit but then you know I get into
it I can get right back into it
alright now that you have all this money
why did you just ditch shirts I'm not
I'm just [ __ ] took out my [ __ ] so I
could dump it dump I have a onesie in it
I can't really take a dump for that
onesie are you wearing a onesie a second
you're going skiing huh you got to get
one with the drop seat they call that a
drop seat yeah I call that easy access
from Mike and MJ all right when you
going to Australia right I'm going
Australia I started Perth April 13th and
14th and then I go to Melbourne and
Adelaide and Sydney and then and then I
finish in Ari I got a big announcement
what - two weeks from today
guess who's going to be in studio Callay
is Campbell almost Defensive Player of
the Year 15 sacks last year for the
Jacksonville Jaguars
another brother of you're talking about
Jalen Ramsay yeah now he's gay right I
wouldn't I don't know why you would say
that and I don't know any I've seen it I
I know quite well I am and tell me he's
not gay the way he dresses the way his
eyes open up the way good he said that I
wouldn't the the best NFL fight of the
year was Jim Ramsey and AJ Green that
fight was like we at work at red though
we were losing our minds for that fight
and we weren't live on it so we're live
on one thing and Andrews watching
something else and then me and the guy
that you met my buddy uh did Andrew lose
his mind trying to get know we were all
work so I can't talk while that's
happening but two of us are watching
that fight in another TV and we're like
like gotta go to this get like you got
to see this you know and then the minute
his mic is dead he's like why are you
guys losing your [ __ ] my did you got us
in this fight you had like it's in its
the best and we showed it like 11 times
during though you know and Watts when
[ __ ] like that happens at red zone it's
like Andrew is you know talking and
doing a replay and whatever and we're
all kind of like looking to set up the
next thing and that fight happens
and all three of us are like losing our
minds and we're just writing notes to
each other because we can't talk oh yeah
and then like we're getting it's called
getting a lot get license-plate numbers
that's what we always hear
I want license plate numbers so I'm like
this guy did this then he came in then
he did this then he tackled him and it
you know and it's the worst when it's
like special teams play so it's like
let's say I'm gonna kick off I slap the
ball out of your hand
somebody else picks it up somebody else
knocks it out of your hand and you pick
it up we got to get all the license
plate numbers so it's like I mean it's
special teams it's a nightmare
because it's nobody you ever heard of
everyone's got number number seven
everyone's number seventeen everyone's
number seventeen everyone know you know
when it's a regular play it's fine and
easy to do you know clay is Campbell for
strip strip sack whatever and then Jim
and Ramsey picks up the fumble on the
special teams it's nuts that fight was
incredible see as big as he looks on TV
equally as camel didn't clear skim I'll
show you a picture of us together didn't
he he's like 300 pounds right did you do
you used to play college football for
University of Miami yesterday he was 70
million dollar contract with sports ban
the sports man knows what he's talking
he's 6-8 like 3 2003 hundred ok I'll
read Ben thank you for correcting me on
there it was born September 1st 1986
he's a young we're both virgos exactly I
don't like black people that's which one
is he said 560 Eccles
yeah 14
so he just went to the store and you
antagonized know his brother has done
punch honk before
nice black guy that you like he wasn't
one of those ugly ones are you okay
let's clear you're all resistant oh
really because all right would you sleep
in a black girl I would sleep with a
black girl you're the one that's like I
was only with you know who's cute the
one that stayed in khloe kardashian he's
very attractive
which one Tristan Thompson who's very is
Thompson is I'm blacker than Tristan
Thompson
I am yeah yeah and that's a classic
white move you throw the third one there
like who's like DeAndre Washington the
fifth I'm nobody I'm the fourth are you
the fourth just lazy
Johny Woodard is just lazy white man
that's it that's pure lazy naming yeah
I'm Dave Smith the ninth by the time you
get to the third there's a lot of
pressure you know to keep it going keep
what go yeah I think I'm probably going
to I'm gonna to abandon them I don't
feel like having a kid I feel like you
should you don't even want a kid that's
right that's what I just said yeah yeah
you don't even want a kid I did I
adopted at 17 and dated at 18 I love you
of all of red bands girlfriends re of
olive red bands girlfriends your
girlfriend right now is my alter like I
love your girlfriend and she's young she
won't be 21 for nine years right now
paid a lot of money for that of course
you did I mean literally she's like I
gotta leave I'm just gonna put my
girlfriend in my pocket and then take an
uber
oh god I've seen that fold of the toilet
paper before in that face of
disappointment Oh God Wow don't kick us
off
- all right all right all right your
hola he's sneaky that's why he's sneaky
hey Ari Ari we're only on but you're
only on this show for like a few minutes
because you got to leave don't kick us
off you tight I actually just got don't
be gratuitous don't be gratuitous asked
me to ask you to show me your belt
[Laughter]
ari Ari Ari you should have time like
when Ari gets have a huge announcement
and I briefly announced it last week but
nobody was here except for Sam but he
was on his phone when I said it so no
one heard me say this I was at the store
and I met you've done the horn right in
Austin yeah yeah yeah so those guys are
great
so I was I work for them or all every
Friday I would do football for all 17
weeks so for 17 weeks I would call into
their show and do sports and I met a guy
that's like oh man I [ __ ] know you
from the horn which is rare and weird
it's a sports show in Austin Texas and
I'm like that's great and his friend was
this really cute girl and she and I like
hit it off and we're talking she has a
boyfriend so there's nothing that's
going to happen but nothing was gonna
happen anyway go ahead thank you for
that details Oh what do you mean by that
I mean you're a dork you mean I'm gonna
die alone yeah okay good okay I agree
with that then um so and then we were
talking about podcast and she's like oh
you do a pop what's your podcast I go
it's that you probably never did - no
way you've ever it's punch wrong sports
it she's oh your punch honk I've heard
of that I've listened to that a couple
times I'm like that's for that is for
female listeners that we have found
that's for she said she had listened to
it a couple times briefly and I will
take that do you remember the days that
we work where we had we were like we're
waiting to
our first female listener oh yeah and it
was Mac hard who is like more of a
diketon both of my mom's added together
hi salmon I want to choke out everything
like Jesus Mac dyke that was our first
female listener a couple yeah understand
lesson 10 let's talk after the show
let's talk after that's rude cuz they're
listening and they know that they've met
you at the store that you do that is no
no I'm saying none none of them have
tried to rap to me you know maybe like
anything so if they were cute exactly
exactly yeah that's just life that's
just nature that goes back all the way
that's just that's like Dharma Apes
that's yeah that's darlin that's the
part that's part of Genesis sorry
I've tried them all right and guys I
hate to be this guy and I don't and I
know you're pregnant and you're working
on you know having luck what are you
wearing right now say the latter what
are you wearing you're wearing a fighter
and the kid hoodie so be fair guys I
only have two hoodies that still fit and
this oh those guys are fat Fox they
should I have a good pregnant mother one
was the one that I wore a lot here to
hide my pregnant belly it's like really
big so I just read it too much on camera
those two dumb [ __ ] have fat merch yeah
eternity okay good yeah well this is so
small and it still fit yeah exactly yeah
because those two fat pricks alright
we're gonna [ __ ] those guys up or what
[ __ ] them up
how dare they how dare they give our
[ __ ] nanny Oh [ __ ] sure no no no
don't blame them blame her how much did
you pay for that you know I want to
fight in any shirt speaking of why don't
we have a fight nanny shirt no
why's nobody so you buy their [ __ ] but
you don't even buy your own shirt I
bought this for years ago there's a
shirt with your I mean I'll get you a
free one obviously what do you want
sighs double X you paid money for that
sweatshirt and you do I have it
punch-drunk shirt I have like five but
you don't wear them there's a shirt
named after you and Sam where are all
your own shirts why okay so you bought
one who bought a fighter in the kids
sweatshirt how much was that fifty bucks
I think it was thirty thirty bucks
you bought that shirt it was when I was
just a podcast man and I was still
buying merch yeah Pernell burn it Callen
is just take that off and set it on fire
Aaron are we cool with the fire in the
studio Aaron says yes that's not that's
not he doesn't have a mic but he's
nodding yes there's alcohol over there
which will make the fire bigger yeah I
save I know you get your shirts for free
from hunched trunk is all my complaint
is and that I don't I design I wonder
every single one of them my design hurts
my feeling I will get you a fine Andy
shirt I forgot there wasn't yeah to be
honest yeah dad was wearing one this
weekend I was like hey dad you have my
shirt oh he does yes I'll get you a
fight an t-shirt but when I get her son
you have to burn a fighter in the kid
shirt here in the studio we'll do it
outside Aaron or we'll do it in here and
yeah Aaron says yeah we'll do it in here
I have a white one that's too big so
that's fine
hang on hang on in front of the door let
me text magical if it's cool yeah oh he
says yeah Aaron magical says yes burn it
in here okay I'll bring my white one
why's it got to be why don't you want to
burn a black one I like this I love this
outfit that's the dumb and dumber
that's what Jeff Daniels weren't done
yeah it's so fun because after I saw the
re wearing his snow suit which is a
bright I love writing yarn it looks like
a crossing guard like this is I've seen
like four videos of re wearing this
exact same thing which is basically like
shakes the clown meets of a crossing
guard
but after after I after I saw this I
searched for him there's a lot of fun
snow suits that you can buy like there's
one that just looks like pizza really
yeah like if you watch his ski videos
you're you really are a good at skiing
and it looks very fun what you're doing
I'm just glad he's skiing instead of
snowboarding he hasn't started that [ __ ]
right sorry that is that thing warm it's
okay it's not but it's not cool
have you taken any like crazy spills if
you pulled any kind of like a Sonny
Bono's Jesus [ __ ] snow suit from side
to side air flowing straight to my skin
I thought really sent far uh yeah I've
seen some good spills we saw the guy
Ryan and I saw a guy go through a slow
down fence he went through it just
[ __ ] lay dead on the ground
Wow my friend tore his ACL like he was
[ __ ] up for like eight months because
of skiing and he was like a skier you
skied every day and just one last time I
skied last two years ago I remember that
look
oh that's right I remember that yeah
what was up with that sty in you know
what's his face is I yes that was he was
supposed to be here today and then he
like laughs he text me at like 9:30 this
morning like cam AKP's all right I
almost did the same thing everyone knows
that to me now cuz I mean I woke up him
but why the [ __ ] did I say I'll do it
like we got it your eyes okay
last night literally I'm like hey man
are you free tomorrow is like yeah I'd
like to promote cuz you're doing the La
Jolla thing we'll talk about that and
he's like I would love to come do it and
you were with your 9 year old girlfriend
and then you go I'll probably do it but
she's
and I'm like rut round isn't that funny
that you down there mind that you always
say like when you're drunk you're like
I'll do that I'll do that oh I do it no
it happens to me here's what here's
where drinking and comedy [ __ ] me it's
not like can you do this tomorrow it's
hey man in three in four weeks can you
do my thing I'm like sure man I'll do it
hit me up about it and you don't hear
about it for three weeks and six days
right and then like tomorrow is this
thing you said you would do and I'm like
it's a four-hour drive damn it it's a
four-hour drive in the desk I agreed to
a Pacoima gig okay I think I think Ari's
gonna race Formula one now I know Ari
who do you [ __ ] uh Mario Andretti
yeah yeah how cold is it there Mario and
Joey you uh what's going on right now
pretty warm nothing's going on now you
don't look but yeah it looks absolutely
warm in what you're wearing it's 75
degrees at 75 degrees and uh yeah you
look like you're like formula fun it's
like the worst snake eyes ever really I
said we were things you [ __ ] no
really it was a dumb pun the reason I
tried I know some don't you try bro and
it doesn't work out [ __ ] heroes like
all right wouldn't you look at us in the
new studio is it weird are you look
you're looking at the back of our heads
right because we're looking right in
your face yeah we get used to it or is
it weird like if I do this if I do this
to Seymour you're like oh that feels
more personal yeah I guess better it's
not matter you well then we can't see
yeah we can see through that that
monitor yeah yeah but if this is better
for you I'll do it yeah yeah Ari I might
died this weekend yeah well not this
weekend but like in the next two days I
am going to Vegas right after this show
be
as a friend of mine has a little bit of
money and he is going to bankroll me
teaching him how to play blackjack which
is what I did do you remember when we
were in Vegas when you run out and
remember you're like wow oh now I get it
oh and then who made money remember when
it is that one re used to carry around
poker books everywhere he went leveling
but that was way after that but I do
remember that I would carry on a card
yes thank you I remember that yep and I
am so I'm going to Vegas and I am
playing blackjack for 16 hours in two
days and I get to keep whatever I win
and my hotel and my cards are paid for I
just got to pay for food so it goes that
I could die five hundred a night two
nights okay just like immediately one
hand here yeah and then it's like well
this didn't work out for either of us
but no I'll be doing like $5 hands with
500 bucks and he'll be doing like $50
hands with whatever he's doing so we'll
see but if I don't if I'm not on the
next punch-drunk it's because I died and
I was killed by the Mafia ladies and
gentlemen so is your is your the place
you're staying right now can you pretty
much just go outside and just go skiing
right out there already I know you're
putting on your boots yeah but you can't
really walk around those boots so great
so it must be pretty close that's yeah
yeah re you literally are living the
dream that's alright what gigs do you
have coming up what do you where you
going and you're in Canada you're a
Whistler right but you're in Canada
you're a Whistler right now so I got on
Friday Sunday and then we just got to
gear I got Syracuse and Albany before in
April before I go to Austria
and then you're all straight and then
when you win you back here because the
number one question I get the most I
mean obviously I know what it is yeah so
what's the answer
winner hot dogs going in butts that
aren't yeah but uh next I'm there but
the problem is I get this which is what
to win people hey when he give you back
in LA like that shows or whatever and my
answer is hopefully never yeah he hates
it here why don't why do you hate it so
much here I just if people have gotten
more and more garbage you know idea one
sanctuary might have the Comedy Store
has become like a fan place it's it's it
you can't hang out the front patio
anymore just [ __ ] chill it's too
popular it's like it's fine it's good
that's going well but like it's just
like yeah no no man not uh that was the
only good place and now LA itself it's
gotten way worse with Instagram it's not
creatively completed it's not conducive
to create tally for me for me it used to
be like I used to feel creative and like
it felt like this artistic community and
now feels like a business it feels like
everyone's met you know and then I feel
like because I'm not a Bert Kreischer or
one of these big that I've been like
thrown to the wayside and then my
creativity has been I feel like I'd be
more creative in Chicago or somewhere
else
um Chicago Chicago like happiest when he
was there though really yep and he did a
lot of stand-up yep
and like all the it's just rehab it
might be it might be I don't know I just
IRA mantas eyes being like I'm in LA for
a half a year I'm in Chicago forever
you're like how far does with New York
that would be probably my like chief and
then Sam does Vegas in here there's just
no punch oh yeah you know yeah Sam does
I can AVN's
and all of you on skype at the same time
that would be great
that would be like yeah that's like
that's like if like if I was like Earth
got blown up and then like everyone
lives in space like that's how podcast
would be
it would just be all still alive though
why are we in different places why
really everyone's just like no none of
the same ship at all okay no one's on
the same ship the good thing about the
Comedy Store is that they debt they do
have that VIP bar now in the back so you
can kind of escape for that but I get it
it's not ever the [ __ ] cokehead
managers are there there's tons of
people they don't even know and they're
all the time yeah that's true they don't
police as they should at least me right
the [ __ ] out of there once don't ever
let that happen again hey TC show oh
dude
bro all you got to do is say and listen
I will put my name on the line for you
all you have to say is I know Ari
Shaffir that's all you really have to do
okay yeah it's just gotten weird but
that's it's not the store the stories
through the refuge and it's no longer
the refuge so like so like the rest of
LA is just encroaching and it's just
like gotten way worse I mean I didn't
know if I was just because I was gone or
what but it's like there's this vapid
this there's this neat little thing I
bet it was always there watching Ari
like lonely music I'm gonna be the guy
who listens to country music right I'm
gonna try to be somebody right instead
of just being yourself and then just
being who you are I bet I bet if you
leave and come back you see that a lot
more than you know be you know like if
you're like a PJ Stansberry where you're
like I haven't been here in two years
and you come back you're like displaces
different he's gonna come back so
different PJ I am watching Ari get ready
for this it's like watching like like
someone looks like I like a like a
suicide bomber like slowly strap on like
all of his yeah all right guys see you
later like he was naked when we saw him
five minutes ago he was stretching and
naked and now he has like it's making me
want to ski I haven't skied in maybe 20
years and I miss it now just watching
him pronoun outfit
guy he's wearing a helmet I've never
worn a helmet before this guy's [ __ ]
around is that the new thing wearing a
helmet
this black diamond Johnson over here
black diamond Johnson is everybody
wearing helmets though yeah Wow wait are
you going down black diamonds for real
are you just going oh yeah excuse that's
a great trip right a black diamond elect
timing ladies and gentlemen give it up
for black diamond that's weird because
back when ice skate I don't think I've
ever seen anyone wear a helmet back when
I was a skier yeah because you skied in
Ohio yeah I know but but I think that's
something new kind of like when backing
when you're kids no one wore seat belts
and this happened last night you know
what I hate is like when you're getting
a backseat of a car in a uber and you
get in you're like hey man what's up
you're like are you Jason yeah you're
Dave yeah you do that call uber thing
and then you sit in the back and you put
your headphones and he's like oh put
your seat belt on
yeah I hate when a driver tells me to
put my seat belt on in the back seat I
always put my seat belt on
no [ __ ] yeah I guess that's true I mean
it's nice yeah you know what I tell you
you take yours off I'm paying you take
your seatbelt off cuz I think you're
gonna drive safer if your seat belt is
all I'll kill you somebody wants her
baby kicked out of her today notice that
in the backseat it's only in the front
today that's my point
it's like that no it's not a lot
it literally is not a law she is correct
who's Annie is accurate you have to have
a seatbelt on the back seat in the car
you gotta have a seat [ __ ] Aaron
kill Aaron's mic
Aaron kill his mic
Aaron kill Aaron kill Aaron's mic and
killed nannies
you're getting kicked out of you bat
writers in the backseat did not have to
wear seatbelts after a certain age
passengers can ride in the backseat
without wearing seat belts ranging from
the age 17 to 18 depending on state law
why can't I still hear you I can seek
health why can i still have Aaron why
can i still hear her I can hear her turn
your volume down no no it's not that
that's not the issue I got it look at
this guy now you look like alright now
it's like now it's like looking at a
[ __ ] yeah yeah exactly it's like
looking at a priest and marvel you we're
looking at a Marvel movie the best part
is I can't I'm fairly certain he can't
show his [ __ ] now by quickly not yeah
not for about seven minutes yeah this is
the best thing that's ever happened in
this show I wish he could just like open
his patio door and ski out this is like
x-men meets Schindler's List that's
what's happening right now
spider-man spider-man ch
nobody knows what a spider-man wow you
look like you are not [ __ ] around and
you're like it's a beautiful 70 degrees
and you look like you're literally
walking into a nuclear holocaust ari Ari
is that a phone you have it looks like
you have a looks like you have he does
have a phone ari has a phone not your
lottery ticket [ __ ] what's your phone
what phone do you have on the phone
you're using for FaceTime hold up to
your mask Ari right there I swear to God
right there with the helmet and with the
thing all the way up to your neck and
then the thing around your chin and I
can only see your nose and mouth and
your goggles yeah
good looking guy right there like I'm
like is that Tom Cruise
like literally gorgeous
it's the most gorgeous I've ever seen
you look take it all off and I'm just
like go but right now I I mean like
leading man handsome like brush your
teeth after I miss you buddy that's not
even like a real it's not even like it's
just like one of them like oh oh ask him
about skanks the pube beard hey hey are
y'all up you beard Ferrari true or false
you lost a bet on legion of skanks and
you have to wear a pube beard of
everybody from that show that's what
we've heard and people are talking about
a lot you have to wear a pube beard on
all of the people from Legion of skanks
even even what was that
yep that's true and everybody please
everyone please tweet at Legion of
skanks Ari has to wear our pew beard
from everyone from Legion of skanks I
know it's true because I've heard it a
lot of fans have hit us up apparently
you lost some sort of bet and that has
to make it happen just do it you lost
pay it up I feel like that is our look
they ripped up ripped off all right
sports fans are they doing just see you
dealing everything you guys do everybody
is is that the new podcast now this
fighting anyone have a [ __ ] I saw
that on sir I saw that so somebody had
tweeted at Gomez I know like hey I love
your podcast is there any other podcast
that our comedy related and talk about
sports and gum has tweeted back nah dawg
just us I know Mike really [ __ ] really
really
well I mean Emma Mayen when uh I mean I
don't have class Campbell Defensive
Player of the Year in the NFL but the
Player of the Year nucleus Campbell was
also on the Legion yes he was
or League I mean the league [ __ ] the
league with renze who was supposed to be
on today but then he cancelled last
minute that would have been so funny if
we both did too and it was just you what
would you have done
yeah I'm sorry you dominated just oh I
had the funniest podcast in the history
of time taking calls calls I do if it's
just team okay okay we'll take calls
today we'll take calls today
Aaron what's the number 500 the number
is 500 you're watching that because of
Brent woods no no no we're good we good
time we got three to three to eight to
seven forty four three two three two
eight two seven four to four accurate is
what it is but and what we're gonna
start doing is the last half-hour of
every show now now that we can take
calls
we'll take calls the last half-hour used
to be a rule it used to be a rule and
now it is again so everyone calm down
I see people calling in right now calm
down jab calm down garnet everybody
Garnett's like I got it I quit my job to
call in today now everyone calm down
we'll do it in the last half-hour we're
talking to re right now that usually
works telling them to calm down Oh too
bad
ari can't all this down but now it's
getting crazier like now he's just got
goggles walking around his apartment
with [ __ ] skis on like I'm gonna seem
stupid II can't ski and talk to us at
the same time are you all right take
your [ __ ] iPad to the slopes well
take your iPad to the slopes and let's
see how long we can do anything
Wi-Fi imagine if there is an a camera in
this place what's Airbnb like the owners
just think he's talking to himself
look at this poopy iPad I'm a loon
period this guy's just walking around
with skis on in the apartment talking to
nobody
ari I had to moon period that lasted two
weeks and he keeps like white ass and
holding it in front of his computer
what's going on with this guy got two
weeks man I thought I was about to go to
the doctor because it lasted two weeks
what would you know yeah Moon Moon
Pierre is that what does that mean
moon periods usually only lasts a couple
days dub moon Pierre you say that like
blood and it's based on the main yeah
not getting enough water is that what it
is I would say no it's just hammer
enough water because I drink maybe six
of these little bottles of water a day
that's enough right like coffee and
stuff because that makes you piss it out
faster I drink one thing a coffee
usually what is that oh are you gone
what was that I love how teeb just wakes
up and joy come it's too much fun a 1
liter of Coca Cola not even diet cokes
it's a 1 liter it was half gone it was
half gone from like the last day or so
and then I woke up this morning and I
had water and a coffee and then I was
leaving and the Johnnies picked me up
and like oh I'm gonna grab this and
finish it and I'll drink this you know
later I've really cut down on how much
soda I've drank lately it's so bad
weight is still yeah I know it's bad for
me and but I drink I have what's a can
12 easily 36 ounces of Coca Cola a day
yeah one two three cokes today why not
if you include Jack and cokes or mixing
you know I easily have yeah 700 I don't
know but the equivalent of three cans a
day and not diet why not tell me why not
Coke Zero taste the same Wow you always
hear because you always hear that
dye cokes worse than regular yeah I
don't know about that I think sugar
you're hang on I mean no I mean people
do say that I just don't believe I want
to dedicate this to magic
I mean gravity works then still good
high five now Ari has his goggles off
good hi wake up
what now he's taking everything off just
like he now he looks like he'd like it
like he's about to fight what if he
doesn't even go skiing he just wears
[Laughter]
he's cosplaying it ski he's at the old
you do he's at the old studio that was
his dominatrix [ __ ] Ari will you retweet
my all right
will you retweet my video are you back
on Twitter yet hey Ari we can give you
that sorry forever forever ever
permanently Wow
so you can't just do Ari Shaffir - I
know well I'll say it is Sam Tripoli
tried to take Ari Shaffir as new account
he changed his write account - it kind
of new are you gonna trick to me a
couple times yeah oh yeah oh hey Tillery
Clinton all of a sudden all right Sweden
about Hillary Clinton every at 4:00 a.m.
all the time like wow this is uh that
seems awkward you should see that ass
mentions for punch-drunk it's just it
was yeah I love James who's always day
oh look at this look at this look at
this all right let's get all the way in
I want two bites and I want those for
the second bite to be there
small guys let's look at this I want the
SEC show us how it's done
one byte get it no deeper deeper deeper
deeper pull back out pull it out now
pull it out don't bite it pull it out oh
that's my bra it's like marina that's a
nude being a bra right there that's a
bra been bro
are you looking the sides who looks a
banana bro oh my god Ari swear to god
that's literally the best [ __ ] our
head of my life and Ari we have to talk
now shove it all in take it off one bite
one bite one bite all of it get it all
in your mouth all of it all of it you
[ __ ] pig or he's gonna die alive yes
Oh God in heaven Aaron if there's a God
in heaven that happens because we will
get what someone buy this show yeah
that's Danny that's the name of this up
one bite banana is the name of this ass
Johnny one bite banana was really
impressed
oh I knew that forever yeah I was that
everyone knows that what years of the
circus of books yeah yeah Ahri's mouth
is like a clown car thanks hearing you
guys have a mic I can hear them laughs
guess what guess what the first person
on our ease MySpace page honest top
eight is oh my god you know that you
know that can you look it up for all of
us all right what do they say 50 cent
[Laughter]
what about team well who do you think it
is if you were to say Heather O'Boyle
you think well that was that time I'm
alive I guarantee you she's okay okay
you were tb7 oh [ __ ]
first thing that pops up is a picture of
me and my ex-girlfriend in you oh that's
nice
when I'm in the background my god yeah
okay so you're top person on your top
eight with somebody named rags II uh
killing Barnes of course what a
wonderful herb band is a lover to learn
and then Sam Tripoli and Brian Jarvis
and me that's your Oh awesome five
people I'll take all those babe I know I
know I know rags yeah I know Kelly
Barnes from Jarvis let's see what Sam -
what do you think Sam please I know who
it isn't
Hillary Clinton is giving back then Bill
Hicks Johnny Cash let's see Danny were
you on my face I deleted everyone
deleted it it's right man pocket the
entire history of podcasts in the world
women exhibitors I read them oh I do
there's some good tea that's why I run I
got that [ __ ] tattoo actually where
is that TiVo where was that I was at
that that does ship in Long Beach you
can go she does like aircraft yeah I
think it was a run Reagan yeah that's it
yeah yeah that's when I was wearing
neckties as belt you have a tattoo yeah
see right there you can see is that it's
a Sanskrit symbol for ohm like an old
Rogan bit who isn't that's what I was
wearing neckties for belts oh yeah and I
would tie a belt like a tie but just
first style or you couldn't afford about
no no sure so wait there's there's a
there's a photo in your myspace you see
it's you had a premiere of a movie
called tripping forward in Beverly Hills
in 2006 and you're doing the most pouty
as' lips oh no no no let me do this
right next to Kristen Bell yeah that was
one of the greatest things ever because
guess who else is on that
Paige jennifer Love Hewitt I believe it
was like a team like TMZ or whatever
like it wasn't but like Hollywood thing
where like all the people that were
doing premieres so I was hosting a movie
screening and because I was hosting it
you know our basis of it like hey
everybody bah bah do like 10 minutes and
then set up the movie and then they were
and I was very small camp like very
small cameo in it and because I was
doing that I had to do the walk through
the thing and I was just like [ __ ] it
but then the next day they used my photo
of that pouty face in like the whole
thing so he'd be like here's all the
movie premieres of this weekend you know
and you and mine was the thing I knows
me and Jennifer Love Hewitt on the same
page wow if that's not a people don't
know he's in love with Jennifer Love
Hewitt to this day yeah to this day
really oh she's probably mine Dave that
girl top five top five for sure I mean I
met her once
who's the girl in the notebook and
Rachel McAdams is my number one right
now pregnant she's my number 50 right
now rachel mcadams now down to 50 and I
I you know I like their Mohsen what's
that last she was so hot in true
detective oh and now she's pregnant I'm
a bummer
well that just ruined my goddamn I like
the chick from your right leg the people
are gross
re they're the worst
oh look at already smoking pot now look
at already smoking pot he puts on 50
layers of [ __ ] like why didn't you do
that first pot first [ __ ] oh you
know I say why I say why it took him
literally 20 minutes to put on this
entire uniform if he smoked pot first it
were taking him 50 minutes yeah I got
every goddamn thing on I'm gonna take a
couple rips and then I'm gonna go kill
it
sorry i re Missy buddy bye
alright P Bert Kreischer is my space he
has his shirt off can you find a nanny
yeah do you remember what your myspace
was no yeah you know you don't even
wanna yeah it was like just remember how
my Twitter was a dumb handle before too
is just like I typed letters remember
there was the same thing like I just
didn't care but I you deleted yourself
when you got I remember mine yep let's
see what bill bird myspace looks like I
haven't looked at MySpace and so long
especially let's see Bill burr yep it
looks exactly the same and his top
people is Joe - Joe DeRosa hmm yeah -
Keith Robinson Robert Kelly yeah yes
that's pretty much yeah the same he's
always been a groom for a success Dave
Attell and the rest of us not so much
not so much cheese red band you are
going to La Jolla yeah this third this
we do so it's Tuesday now so Thursday
just doing the one night one night with
Jeremiah Watkins we're just doing an in
and out kind of show co-headlining so
we're doing two shows are just one I
just I think we're just doing one we're
doing with Matt ryf also but just one
show in and out but we're also taking
kill Tony to Phoenix Arizona and stand
and a blast and apply oh so that's gonna
be a lot of fun and that's next month
listen that when we were there for and
we we shared a hotel room that was so
much fun at the all things comedy
podcast festival it was seem so fun
you're gonna have a great time what a
great club great staff yeah I've done it
it's the best pretty funny story so
remember when I was addicted to those
boner pills all the time oh yeah and so
every time
to a new city of we know I would take
one like any city I go to it'll be like
you know tried different you know
over-the-counter like gas station rhinos
you know but he because if you go to
different cities they have different
ones girl was the best of that this was
like the last time I did it though
because what happened was right before
show I decided to take one and it [ __ ]
with my blood pressure or something and
I I just started seeing trails exactly
does that yeah and it just starts seeing
trails everywhere and I had to go on the
stage I remember telling the audience
like hey just so you know I'm you were
tripping up bugger I'm stripping my ass
off on boner pills I had to do like a
40-minute set while everyone was melting
and just trails and I was like I could
have when it's good though what's the
pleasure of just having an erection or
is it kind of speedy no no it's it's
what's great about it is that you can
talk a lot a lot you can [ __ ] a lot and
then come and then in one minute you're
ready to [ __ ] again it's like you you're
it's the hardest you've ever been yep
you're Bonin and it everyone's away even
when you come it's on call like non-stop
so it's really not it's really more for
her like boner pills are not for men
because it's so deflating when you like
ejaculate and then you're like I'm out
I'm out and sorry sorry
but so you can get the first one out of
the way you're embarrassing ejaculation
is gone and then you're like this next
one's for you like American Pie right I
do it for a different reason I used to
do it just because like yeah you know
how I'd love to hear why you do it well
you know how people like like guys
always show girls are dick pics you know
like there's something to that never
sent a dick pic in my life right what
what a lot of people do but I love to do
it I love to do it and then like go
somewhere like a massage parlor or
something so when it's like a real-life
dick pic instead of so when they flip
you over you're just she's like oh my
god and it's way better than a dick pic
because you get to see the reaction yeah
you're more like I like I like flip this
house with this house kind of [ __ ]
like I just watched this is so gay to
say but I watched like 5 hour or five
episodes of the new query
people been telling me there's a Netflix
yeah it's unnecessary to lit one thing I
don't like we're just a couple things
all the gays no it used to be called
Queer Eye for the straight guy and the
whole point was that's called queer eye
now it's called queer eye because one
episode at least they had a gay guy and
he didn't need a haircut he already had
a fat pad and so it's kind of like
alright this this is defeating the idea
of it right there's a few good ones
there's a couple touching ones where I'm
just like oh my god yeah yeah or the the
old guy that had like the pro Pete at
the [ __ ] you know and I just felt sad
it's it seems like they're getting
deeper into the story this time around
you know instead of like let's just flip
this guy you know yeah it was good it
was surprising for sure for sure read
for what oh well you know the people to
make this happen to people kind of
sponsors you guys got going on right now
well we got a lot but today here's
what's up
March Madness what's around the corner
what about some great and by the way
great fights and you I know you're a
boxing guy oh you and I are huge
pugilist fans great fights this week if
you want to go and and this is literally
the time of the year to do that's on
parlays sweet 16 the turning of 64 go to
betty si.com
use the code punch 25 what does that get
you take it you 25 free bucks
Wow literally you can bet with free
money on even if you just like I like
college basketball I am going to put my
money on college about 25 bucks then
fill out a bracket cuz they're gonna
have them and if you put 20 your 25
bucks on your bracket and you win wow
that's like 10 bucks maybe
a lot more than that a lot literally
you would be thousands it would be
thousands so go to bet deicide I come
use the code punch 25 that gets you 25
free bucks if you put in let's say you
put in 50 bucks
after that guess what they do now you
got another 50 they double it you put it
in 100 now you got 200 you know and and
they've got live betting now so you can
live betting a UFC
baseball is coming around the corner
which I'm excited for so many wearing a
aaron did you see the color of the Cubs
hat no oh because it's gold you only get
to wear the gold when you win the World
Series
yeah I know we won two of them yeah yeah
yeah oh you're not wearing that
okay I'm wearing one I get it so use the
code punch one two five and that get you
25 free bucks
I'm excited for the tourney I always am
I don't care about how I really anybody
they're like 10 I know you do if you are
diehard now when it comes to like all
supports let's go all sports
where does Carolina basketball rank in
comparison to the pennant NFL and the
Panthers tied with NFL it's number one
yeah with NF oh yeah would you rather
have Tar Heels win well just because
they've won so much I mean they won
three championships in the last 15 years
so I would rather have the Panthers win
the Super Bowl or then when a football
championship did you hear Panthers sign
diagram gone oh I'm gone oh wow most
bats do there's a good gram guano for
your contractor oh thank you
oh really for daddy's old for four years
he won't but he will not see was the
highest highest percentage in the league
last year
Falcons just Rianne similar fashion
re-signed Matt bryophyte
who is my age good he's so good he's 43
he's 41
really 41 kicker and he's still in the
NFL and thank you for seeing him 43
because I'm 45 I was just gonna say like
for four years they sign this man till
he's 50 years old three years three
years so they signed him from four to
you is he still really good yeah yes oh
yes oh yes news kick butt
you've acted like somebody that is well
two years younger than me is still in
the NFL it gives me hope NBA in the NBA
everybody that I had a poster of when I
was a kid is a coach oh that's a bummer
Scott Skiles like all those like anybody
that like or an analyst Chris Webber
Shaq everybody that I grew up loving is
now either a coach or an analyst yeah
well I'm seeing guys get to be another
Matt Bryant yeah this guy's still
kicking [ __ ] field goals for my
favorite team
like look at Morton Anderson he finished
his career with the found innocent oh my
god oh my gosh 2007 he played in the NFL
he is the all-time leading scorer for
two different teams crazy Saints and
Falcons all-time leading scorer and he
kicked till he was like 44 born in
Denmark born in Denmark gained a Dane
isn't he like six feet to 6 I heard I
heard that yeah he's 6-2 6-2 Danish a
soccer player but I've kickers are of
course Ribbon sports man you know that
yeah follow him I like his well I think
it's named Jennifer I always like
Jennifer Anderson yeah what a dumb [ __ ]
ladies of course who doesn't know
Jennifer and there's an Anderson how
about this fight so so you think you're
pretty sure that Joshua will take care
of Wilder right
Deonte why honor I do if you want to
talk boxing I think and by the way let's
go bet dsi we have on Cinco de Mayo
two amazing fights that are coming up
with triple G and Canelo and and
congratulations boxing and whoever is
promoting this not only do you have
triple G and Canelo but there is another
fight before that that is also equally
as prevalent and that's what boxing
means to do what UFC does because what
boxing does is they go
here's Mayweather Pacquiao and then
here's four things you don't give a [ __ ]
about before it but now if you go here's
two title fights and two things you
don't care about now you got my money
and now you got my attention and I think
boxing has done that based on the model
that the UFC
yeah you got it if if you want
pay-per-view money if you want me to
give you $60 it can't just be one good
fight and a bunch of [ __ ] because of
that one fight is just Mayweather
dancing around and getting a win I will
never get another [ __ ] pay-per-view
again but if you give me two good fights
and it's got your right so now I'm
listening and now my credit card is is
is going to you know Direct TV or AT&T
or whatever the [ __ ] you you're doing
yes we're just getting enough be cool
Johnny
I never I've never said this before but
I miss Sam I don't believe that for a
minute you are right didn't Canelo just
test positive for a banned substance no
no Ronnie Yoga when it was Tony yoga he
was given a one-year suspension actually
thank you sports man uh you know what he
said he said it was bad cow meat it was
it was what he said no you're exactly
right you're exactly right Kandace he's
allowed to fight he said bad come he
said it was Mexican cattle yeah
have hormones that are not are given
treated with hormones that are not
standard to the u.s. not like you fight
once you get caught but it depends on
what it is and so why John John say he
had some action in town because he
crashed his car into a pregnant woman no
came back to get his pot and remash and
out of his rental car that was three
years ago this is like just steroids he
was getting tested for now no he's like
I've been eating all the red meat that
I've been eating and they believe this
this is real no no they don't they have
to all of them conspire and go what's
the lie we are going to go with to still
make seven hundred million dollars that
90 people split so they don't have
strict rules like the UFC in boxing
that's the problem with boxing is that
it is so political it's literally it's
boxing boxing boxing has always been
like Trump as president boxing since
post Mike Tyson boxing has always been
Trump as president but it's it's the
step in a way will spin a way to keep it
there's no liquid will spin a way to
keep it liquid financially and everyone
will believe what we say you know it's a
lot like Lance Armstrong has it have you
seen that doc Icarus
or the Lance Lance on it's on Netflix
yeah I know your time I haven't seen I
don't wanna you know I never want to do
that but I cheated guilty guilty and
it's fascinating because it's done from
a guy that's like I did this documentary
then this happen and then I believed him
I believed him and he was so nice even
when it didn't he was being honest and
then like it's the documentary was done
during and
post The Oprah interview and then he
went back and tried to do it again and
he's like I'm gonna do it clean and I'm
just gonna try it and kind of bullied
people kind of bullied people Kenan was
like an [ __ ] and the guy doing
documentary was like still like I
believe in you know he was I'm drinking
his kool-aid I'm drinking it how does he
come off throughout throughout the thing
boom Lance Armstrong awful because at
the end of the documentary he's like and
then he did it one more time and he
tried to do it and he's like I'm gonna
do it clean and there's no point for me
to do it but I'm gonna do it I'm gonna
prove the world I'm clean post Oprah
guess what happened did they get him yes
without a run right guess what happened
yeah he did it again
yeah he's an idiot man has to test it
again and he's like man he lied so the
guy doing the documentary is basically
like he has lied to me from the
beginning to the end and then he
swindled me back to believe that he is
you know trying to turn it around yeah
yeah almost like an alcoholic it's like
I'm done drinking and then you're like
ah you're drunk again it's like that
kind of like and he [ __ ] did it again
at the end it's a pathological yeah it's
a great documentary on Netflix what's it
called do you round it's called it's
called look it up different Ron lie the
Armstrong lie yes stop it nothing the
Armstrong story is that it there's a
bunch of document the Armstrong lie
young sort alive 13 I think
yeah whatever is the one on Netflix
right now that can we go to my suggested
for you right now
yeah I mean we went him on myspace from
[ __ ] 12 years ago the I thought it's
just funny our listener Chris tweeted at
us the Clippers of sign did you see this
the an empowerment badge with the dating
app Bumble so they're there their patch
on their Jersey is gonna be that dating
app Bumble they're calling it a gender
equality badge up Sam will love that
whoa stark state dog stars bro deep
state I mean Oh deep dude that's how
little I know about that [ __ ] so read
ban yeah La Hoya oh yeah boy at this
Thursday with Jeremiah Watkins at the
Comedy Store in the holy oh and kill
Tony is killing it
yeah we had a great show last night
packed audience with Jeff Ross it's a
lot of fun we're just blowing the [ __ ]
up lately it's uh I mean so la main room
it's been like crazy yeah main room I
was hanging out with uh and we were
talking about this before the show but
John Mayer who is I can't stress this
enough I know a lot of punch run fans
would be like there goes a douchebag but
no he's not he is cool as [ __ ] and he
and I were talking three weeks ago just
like one-on-one in the back bar were the
only people in the room which is cool
for me because I'm like oh I'm actually
talking this could you know an exec you
ever noticed that like every time we
talk to a girl every time you talk to a
girl one of three things is happening
she's either cold
she's tired or she's hungry and if she's
hungry she ate recently but she can't
believe she's still hungry and if she's
tired she slept nine hours last night
and she can't believe she's still tired
right
ever since he said that it's always been
true I'm talking to my sister I'm
talking about mom I'm talking to Jackie
Gold I'm talking about to Sarah from
92.7 a pot every time we like I'm
[ __ ] tired but I'm like [ __ ] I'm just
gonna plow through it and I slept so
much last night but I'm [ __ ] or it's
like I'm so cold right now and I know
it's 70 degrees but I'm like tired cold
it it's cold tired hungry
I think that's every
anytime and that was not right now if I
if we were outside I think the
underlying I would say is that man I'm
hungry I think you're always or I'm
tired I'm gonna go back to bed
or you know that's pretty much what
everyone maybe you're a girl I probably
think adults are just over Brian we're
trying to [ __ ] on women right now if I
only sleep like three four hours a night
I would love night out
shut up ladies three hours a night I
knew that but you would always mean I
know you is like I mean we live together
so you like you would go to bed at like
1:00 and you wake up like 9:00 that's
how I work now and plus when you're
pregnant it's very uncomfortable and you
have restless leg so every day tells me
I've slept for hours and I cry every
morning you know the bad Fitbit tells me
to kill myself you know the best thing
about her being pregnant is that after
she has a baby anytime she laughs she's
gonna pee a little
[Laughter]
you're gonna start leaking oh yeah I
don't know I think it's just are you
willing to have your baby live in this
video Aaron Aaron Aaron magical you
section me I just got a text a magical
yes have a baby live in the studio all
right are we good
that's a thumbs-up will you have a baby
live in the studio are you gonna
c-section it what about a D section I
mean that's right that's where I rip
your baby out of your [ __ ] are you
gonna record it are you gonna record it
Jesus to you young lady how dare you
really soon five weeks is your vagina
already starting to smell it's the first
this is the first all things comedy baby
that wasn't aborted true or false it
starts smelling though yeah baby
you know the babies go in the bathroom
inside you so you you're pretty much
like a porta potty until you have a baby
babies baby starts taking it like four
minutes at four minutes you have to like
yeah do damage control in the stink
you have diviner dilating no no it's all
about like the Mexican baby puking out
of your clam Johnny doesn't smell yet
you're on that no should we show the
oscar video oh yeah as you know teep
does the thing called 92.7 the pod which
I do a podcast in a place called town
and I was on the Sara laman and I were
on the Oscars and graduations thank you
man I appreciate that but they well I
thought we thought we were doing the in
memoriam and it turns out they just had
us do the in memoriam for people that
were hashtag me too and so their careers
are dead yeah and and so are ours so
here's a here's the video that we that
came out today you can go to all things
comedy calm and watch this and like it
if you would I appreciate that but
here's what happened please welcome from
92.7 applause
many bright lights went dark in 2017
they entertained us they touched us
artists that are no longer with us too
often names slipped through the cracks
and although they may be gone their
impact will stay with us always let's
take a look at some of the stars we've
lost this year
there's some that had a shake
[Applause]
get in ladies
[Music]
[Applause]
okay
can you prove that you didn't offer to
save my job if I let you blow me
that's a good photo - what all he had it
was a bad date
when it kicks in they get all huggy
buggy
I love our
a good video
that's a great video yeah thank you
buddy
so that whatsapp you edited all things
comedy ma'am everybody here in keep it
in the keep it in the farm that's cool
that's what we say you confirm that Aziz
Ansari's in there because this is a
conspiracy theory in the comments on
YouTube that al magical hates Aziz
Ansari and he's did he order you to I
don't think it's true he order you to
put can you confirm or didn't know I
just love the fact that like it's gotten
so ridiculous that someone can have a
bad date yeah
and you know I mean well I think I think
it's that was Sarah and I Sarah and I
who who I do 92.7 the pod with she never
talked to me like and she's like I miss
the days when like a guy would just lean
in to kiss me yeah without you know and
just like be in the moment
yeah and then I get to just go like you
know actually I don't have feelings for
you and then the guy would be like oh
you know what okay cool
you know my bad I just you know just and
then you just move on now it's like I
leaned in to kiss a girl and she's like
you know like a so here for my lawyer
it's like a soft rape and it really is
like weird and I think that what's
happening is like women are missing that
like they are depriving themselves of
that genuine moment because there's been
so many disingenuous moments of people
trying to manipulate finally we had a
woman here it's kind of I was gonna say
every girl I know agrees that the
aussies thing is ridiculous everyone
your tois Weinstein I'm so wrong didn't
do anything
and I was like series fine I agree
Weinstein what do you what do you really
do
look suck my dick or you get or you
can't be my real bill - oh you can't be
unkilled and then like I'm not gonna
suck your dick cool I'm gonna beat off
on this fern mm-hmm they're crazy
that's a gentlemen move gentlemen we can
award the crazy thing my wine scenes
even before all this [ __ ] drop even when
you just saw him at the Oscars like a
years ago every time they would show him
you'd still go like Oh God every time
you've never seen that guy you go oh
that guy's our prick yeah that guy's a
nightmare boss I mean you you you've
been one of my best friends for a third
of my life I know how shitty some of the
people are that you have worked for in
the past yeah I know you love your
current bosses but I know in the past
worked for some difficult people but we
but they do some like crazy things were
like oh I'm a nanny and I have to be
here for 10 hours and she's literally
just streaming Netflix well I do
everything yeah and I've been like sick
before yeah and just watching them watch
Netflix yeah why am i yeah like you like
you literally could watch your own
five-year-old yeah but you choose
because you have a doctor husband you
choose to just sit on the couch with
your fat ass and do nothing while you
your husband pay someone to make
macaroni and cheese for your
four-year-old yes live your life [ __ ]
dinky [ __ ]
stinky [ __ ] hey let's look up some of
your past bosses on MySpace just like
different nannies throughout the year
like but but you have to be like imagine
like that like you must think you've
been a nanny for a long time and I've
known you through several families you
have to wonder of like you kind of
raised these kids yeah and you one
family for nine years and and that
family yeah
is very close to them and I know them
they're very cool and like you singing
$8,000 roll or other yeah we're the
poorest people know that there are
[ __ ] and super cool like and your
brother wants to Nate and your brother
and I want to spray her down the boss
yeah she's hot trust me yeah yeah so
like but then like that was like your
yeah into the nanny world and that's
when I met you you were working for that
family
yeah but then those kids got old enough
that they're just like yeah but you
would work for them for like eight years
why are you doing when they were 17
just like mostly personal assistant
because they don't want to get rid of me
but I haven't eight years I love cuz I
was like you guys are adult I have to go
yeah but then like I remember I I
remember John Eyre I remember quite well
when you left that felt like you had
that kind of like moment where you're
like we don't need a name but like you
from age of two to 14 like you raise
these kids with us but like yeah did you
like slowly walk out of the bye Felicia
bye Felicia
they kind of gave you a bye Felicia and
then like I remember all you guys crying
it was like this big emotional thing
where you're like I'll still be a part
of your lives and these kids were like
oh we're getting rid of Candis or fight
nanny we're getting rid of fight nanny
but they're but they're like she won't
be here every day for the you know but
like and you had to tell these kids like
I'll still be a party reliant like I'll
still be I'll still but that had to be
really emotional like the last day of
camp because they were crying like I
still see them I do like sleepovers with
them yeah and they don't know like Six
Flags in the summer when I didn't know I
was pregnant so my baby really likes
roller coasters we want like four times
so they know they know you're having a
baby
yeah and
really cool yeah well they laughed about
it cuz I made a joke like in August I go
I'm late on my period you guys like I
hope I'm not pregnant
and then like I text them like a month
later I was like so I told them before
you told us
I told most people for it told the guys
that's a bunch of sports I enjoy the
resident a boy and a girl and the boys
very artistic mm-hmm right yeah yeah
yeah I've like art in my house it looks
like adults did that he oh people always
asked whether like who did that I'm like
an 11 year old was he kind of bummed out
when he found out you're pregnant
no he's just he's not there yet he's
just like a very artistic [ __ ] smart
kid there are the people that there have
to be the bigger shower and like the
yeah this girl are they still in the
same place as I like little yeah dude
that's a dope house you cats like a
dream house are you guys still doing the
bag of bets here oh it's right behind
you how why don't you guys do something
with her placenta yeah I don't want to
turn it into pills you guys can have it
right turn is that a thing that's a
thing yeah you can turn it into pokey or
something No
oh it's some people do turn it into
bells that gets a tradition in some
cultures - you had me with pills hey I
cook the placenta and eat it after the
baby is born
we'd like a steak like like kind of like
if we like eggs actually I would love
the eggs in there that would save me
like an omelette I'm talking about like
we're talking about like a steak yeah
how are you Sam and team yeah Ari Sam
and nanny eat one I think that's a great
team talks about it why you guys if you
have a cesarean you're supposed to wipe
that [ __ ] all over their face what
whatever comes out you're supposed to
give it some kind of immunity from it
but you're allowed to keep it the
placenta so you should at least put it
in a bucket or a bag or something like
that like in the refrigerator but that's
a good bag of the bag I mean seriously
because I you can't eat it and that's
probably the best bag of bag because
it's you have been fighting that they're
too gay we're gonna wrap it up Oh did
Brent urge you to wrap it up but she's
like I did an extra 20 goddamn minute
girls new she's not as like a thorn I
will be respectful but I would like to
let me see that
plug ease please oh this just because I
want to do there's a new dating site I
plug with the plug plug with Johnny and
everyone's in Vegas I'm gonna come see
me play cards and you're gonna win money
are you gone well next time I see you
you're probably gonna see mr. stinky
pushy I love yous all the time I love
you baby good luck with your baby save
the placenta no just say you're gonna
put it in your yard or some [ __ ] yeah
bird Eliezer I brought this trash oh
[ __ ] just bring the bat in as I love you
I'll see you so the new 92.7 the pod
comes out Thursday it's gonna be great
and here's one commercial that we have
just as a little teaser for a little
problem that I've had in my life which
is getting friendzone too much and I'm
sick of it and if you get friend-zoned a
lot maybe sign up for this website
when we met I knew I liked her
immediately
and I knew I'd never want to have sex
with him at friendzone calm you can find
your perfect match I really wanted to be
there for someone who never could
reciprocate my feelings and I needed
help moving we use scientific methods to
find someone who's not looking for
someone like you I can't tell you how
good it feels to have someone to talk to
about my boyfriend if I ever get one why
does this keep happening to me start for
free today he's a great listener and she
will never love me friendzone comm fewer
dates fewer relationships and fewer
marriages than any other site and thank
you to Jeff Scott absolutely who plays
all the pianos for all of our [ __ ] guys
thank you so much for listening
Aaron's giving me the go kill yourself
or my wife will what will she do Erin
should probably take the house Oh
oh my god we don't want that I mean I
apologize so punch on sports.com web
site is coming out when two weeks and
sports band you are in La Jolla all of
Thursday Thursday
Karim I also come to Nashville Comedy
Festival also going to from Phoenix you
can go to dusk watch stand-up live in
Phoenix stamp Olivia and Tempe improv
we're doing stand-up live for kill Tony
and Tempe improv we're doing we kind of
shows there you got a death squad TV
click on tour dates thank you guys yep
suck it and please listen to 92.7 the
pod the new ones coming out this week
thank you guys for all your support as
always listen to
all things company guys suck it consider
it sucked and Aaron suck it suck it